[Musique]
dès le matin ils réveillent un français
sur trois au petit déjeuner il apporte
le journal le courrier
ils vérifient la météo le smartphone est
devenu incontournable
près d'un français sur deux en possèdent
un
aujourd'hui cet objet multitâche
ressemble moins un téléphone qu'à un
ordinateur et comme tous les ordinateurs
il peut être piraté de plus en plus de
sociétés propose à des particuliers
d'espionner leurs proches en piégeant
leur smartphone un marché qui intéresse
les professionnels du renseignement et
fait craindre aux entreprises la fuite
de leurs données ces pratiques sont
elles légales
pourquoi nos smartphones sont ils si
vulnérable
connexion avec un univers truffé
d'applications malveillantes et de micro
indiscret
[Musique]
dans la famille des espions nous
demandons d'abord la mère celle qui se
sert du portable de son enfant pour le
suivre à la trace
marie vit dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris avec ses deux filles ninon et
sybille c'est le petit déjeuner elles
ont déjà un téléphone dans la main et
vas-y que ces partis le texto ça va
jusque dans le lit le soir et ça
commence dans le lit le matin je veux
même pas le voir mais je sais qu'elle
elle c'est un moment donné arrêté et le
matin je sais que ça va je suis pas
inquiète elle va pas à se réveiller à 5
heures du matin pour textoter elle est
bloquée donc c'est bon bloquée car mari
a posé une condition pour avoir son
smartphone sybille 10 ans a dû accepter
que sa mère y installe un petit logiciel
de contrôle une application proposée par
une société spécialisée et qui coûta
marie 5 euros par mois
[Musique]
l'espionnage et en transparence elle a
décidé avec sa fille de limiter internet
les sms et les appels
le but n'est pas d'aller les flics et de
traquer tout ce qu'ils font ça c'est
simplement de leur envoyer un signal
aussi de leur dire voilà faut savoir que
ça peut être aussi par dangereux mais à
terme si vous êtes sous le charme de ces
produits là parce que c'est séduisant
ces gadgets ces machins ses limites et
ses torts et la musique et des machins
donc 5h15 max je te jure qu'il n'était
pas là 5e tracker gps marie élève seule
ses deux filles
et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'elle est d'un naturel inquiet
bonne journée chez dépêche regarde on
aime bien regarder quand même jusqu'au
bout d'un moment où elle franchi la
grille voyez c'est ça le rôle du parent
même si on sait très bien qu'elle peut
aller nulle part ailleurs
à chaque fois on est tous les parents
regardent est ce que c'est bien à
l'école qu'elle valait oui ça va elle a
passé la guigne de retour à la maison
marie va nous montrer comment fonctionne
le clou troll du téléphone de sybille
depuis son ordinateur elle peut voir ce
que fabrique sa fille sur son portable
là je peux voilà sa consommation par
exemple sur deux jours je sais qu'elle a
reçu 24 sms elle en a émis 30 et que l a
appelé cette seconde mais voilà là j'ai
tout la consommation ça j'avoue je
regarde pas cela dit un jour ça peut
servir et l'application ne rentre pas
dans le contenu des textos ce que je
trouve bien fait rien ça moi je m'en
fous de savoir ce qu'ils se disent que
leur vie privée ou et puis de toute
façon il faut qu'on met le nez dedans je
peux pas dire que c'est pas intéressant
mais les couleurs textoris au club salut
ça va tu es ou mail espionne a trouvé
plus malins quel ou plutôt plus maligne
sybille à tromper la surveillance de sa
mère et a modifié quelques paramètres
s'est connecté elle me l'a dit après et
ça c'était sur le blocage de la
consommation
et si je vais parce que j'avais mis au
début que j'ai autorisé 20 sms par jour
et elle a mis cent vingt 120 kms par
jour
la coquine elle a gelé jetterez de la
main dans le sac
et donc j'ai changé mes identifiants
et pendant que sybille est à l'école
marie peut garder un oeil sur sa fille
car le logiciel qu'elle a installé ne
fait pas que contrôler les appels et les
sms
il permet aussi de la géolocaliser
c'est-à-dire de connaître sa position en
temps réel
ou on est là on est passé par là et
l'école et là c'est le trajet qu'on a
fait ce matin voilà j'ai aussi là la
possibilité d'établir un ce qu'ils
appellent le géo fencing alors c'est
quoi
j'en fais alors je détermine une zone
limitée géographique
c'est cette zone en gros de
l'arrondissement qu'elle peut pas sortir
un peu elle peut sortir mais si elle
sort
j'ai un texto si elle sort je sais
qu'elle est allée au delà de ma limite
donc là j'ai toutes les raisons de
m'inquiéter de médias elle devrait pas
être là moi je suis rassuré de savoir
que si un dépassement s'il ya un
problème si elle l est elle est dans une
position délicate alors là il ya des
moyens de me prévenir il ya des moyens
de savoir et si marie a négocié avec sa
fille l'installation du logiciel
d'autres sont plus cachottier et oublié
d'informer leurs proches qu'ils les ont
placés sous surveillance dans la famille
des espions je demande le mari jaloux
sam vit avec sa femme et sa fille son
précédent mariage s'est terminé par un
divorce
il affirme que son ex femme le trompait
alors avant de s'engager dans une
nouvelle histoire
il a voulu s'assurer de la fidélité de
sa nouvelle compagne et le smartphone de
celle ci est aujourd'hui devenue sa
gorge profonde
une nuit il y à installer un logiciel
espion pendant qu'elle dormait depuis il
suit tous ses faits et gestes en direct
sur ce petit téléphone grille par
exemple je vais recevoir encore
l'information la formation en direct on
a la possibilité de savoir voilà un
appel sortant
si ce qu'il dit le détail de l'appel
sortant je vois la personne qu'elle en
train d'appeler avec numéro de portable
qui se fichent le téléphone grille est
relié en permanence à celui de sa femme
qui ignorent l'existence de l'appareil
officiellement je ne reçois aucune
facture pour ce téléphone je ne reçois
rien et lorsque je rentre chez moi
jamais je souhaitais les familles mais
en fait dans l'approché de téléphone
reste dans mon jeu comme le logiciel de
marie celui de sam permet de
géolocaliser sa cible
l'agent garba localisation je sais que
de la date et l'heure donc dj cliquer
ici
c'était l'été la plage et sa position
divo trop quoi
mais il peut aller plus loin que la mère
inquiète il enregistre les appelle les
emails les sms
sam peut tout écouter et tout lire
plus fort encore il peut suivre en
direct les conversations de sa femme et
même activer le micro de son téléphone à
distance quand il est en veille et
qu'elle ne l'utilisent pas démonstration
comme on peut accéder directement au
téléphone on active le micro à distance
là je n'écoute environnementaux lorsque
le bal en soirée lorsque le voir un
repas je trouve savoir tout ce qui se
dit ou dans leurs ports sam a
immédiatement pris goût à cette pratique
totalement illégal et passible d'un an
de prison
heureusement ils sont tous les premiers
jours c'était une sensation de puissance
d'autres on va dire d'être outillés de
tout comme si on était sur un nuage
on voyait tout ce qui se passe quand on
veut tout ce qui se passe même une
contravention
un policier qui va régler parce que
j'étais au téléphone en conduisant
justement parce que c'était les premiers
jours donc je voulais absolument tout
savoir tout entend tout que m j'ai
peut-être un peu trop écouté même quand
j'y repense mollement mais j'écoutais
tout si je crois depuis quatre ans sam
c'est tout entend tout et ne cherche
aucunement à lutter contre son addiction
il n'a jamais découvert l'adultère et
pourtant il reste pendu à ce deuxième
téléphone si je n'ai jamais été conclu
avec cette forme et ça j'en suis sûr m
crois pas que je pourrais m'en passer
franchement au de 3,26 et la certitude
voilà au jour d'aujourd'hui je connais
dure je veux une super belle histoire
d'avoir
pour sam le bonheur c'est simple comme
un mouchard dans un téléphone et comme
lui de plus en plus deux conjoints ont
recours à ces logiciels espions
notamment lors de procédures de divorce
il y a encore dix ans ces outils étaient
réservées aux services de police et de
renseignement
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut en
acheter un sur internet qui a développé
le logiciel de sam
nous savons que le mari jaloux paye 400
euros par an en belgique près de la
frontière française
nous avons rencontré l'homme qui
fabrique des téléphones espion un
dénommé en dessous
depuis trois ans ils vont ses logiciels
sur son site internet
et assure la hotline numéro bien ou bien
vous prenez un deuxième du bureau
moniteurs que personne ne connaît et ça
c'est la meilleure solution
il a installé son bureau à domicile
d'ici il expédie dans toute l'europe des
téléphones espion qui sont vendus comme
neuf sous plastique
il va en préparer un devant nous en
quelques minutes il
je vais aller chercher la micro carte sd
vous laisser le plastique de fuveau
voilà exactement je prends le logiciel
le produit n'est pas encore activée
donc on va mettre un code
voilà donc on va cacher l'application
iphone application donc déjà là il était
installé
il est caché à 100% déjà là on le
retrouve plus maintenant je peux la
montre et rien ni vu ni connu
le téléphone est piégé près à être
offert ses clients sont des parents
inquiets comme marie des conjoint jaloux
comme sam ou des patrons qui fliquent
leurs employés difficile de me damas
très chiffré là dessus je préfère pas en
belgique comme en france cette pratique
n'est légale que si la cible a donné son
consentement
c'est à dire pratiquement jamais mais ça
le vendeur s'en lave les mains
on peut mettre un téléphone sur écoute à
condition que c'est pas votre compagne
comprenez ça toute façon c'est illégal
par tous parce que ça saigne invasion de
la vie privée ça il faut pas le faire
bon ça c'est pas de mes oignons
c'est comme le vendeur d'un couteau il
n'est pas responsable des actes qui sont
faits avec ton plus c'est exactement la
même chose
c'est ce principe là quoi
et nous allons voir à quel point les
esprits mal intentionnés peuvent nuire à
autrui en prenant possession de leurs
smartphones ils ne sont pas seulement
capable d'espionner ce que les appareils
contiennent ils sont aussi désormais en
mesure d'y ajouter des données
compromettantes
de quoi semer la confusion dans un
procès où dans un divorce
regardez bien cette reconstitution que
nous avons réalisé avec un jeune
ingénieur
ce petit appareil qui s'achètent sur
internet permet d'aspirer des données
edrs en injecter d'autres vous le
dissimuler et vous entrez par exemple
dans un restaurant où la personne que
vous espionnez s'est rendu
discrètement vous lui subtiliser son
smartphone
l'agent n'est pas le téléphone
j'en ai marre ont une pression de touche
pas besoin de connaître son code
alors je le branche
là maintenant mon dispositif a détecté
le téléphone il va venir
aspiré en fait tous les messages pour
réinjecter de nouveau et rajouter des
images dans la photo la plus attendue
sera démarre à la manière des mares
c'est fini
j'en ai maintenant dans la poche en
quelques secondes vous avait injecté des
photos mais aussi de faux sms
l'homme qui fait office de cible de
notre reconstitution est aussi un expert
en piratage de smartphones alors en fait
ils ont injecté des conversations une si
on a une conversation de twic auraient
pu être envoyés par le général de gaulle
un d'athènes 1944 voilà ce qu'a été on
peut injecter effectivement n'importe
quel type de données si on va
effectivement dans dans galerie on voit
ici
l'injection d'une image complète donc ça
pourrait être une vidéo ça peut être une
image en sachant bien évidemment qu'un
sms devant la justice a force de loi
c'est une preuve recevable il peut faire
n'importe quoi on peut faire absolument
n'importe quoi dans la mesure où on peut
complètement modifié l'environnement du
téléphone les pirates malveillants sont
donc capables d'ajouter des données dans
des smartphones pour incriminer les
particuliers mais aussi parfois à
d'autres fins
l'escroquerie par exemple
des virus peuvent être mises au point
pour pénétrer les smartphones et
arnaques et leur utilisateur sans qu'il
ne s'en rende compte
[Musique]
démonstration avec dylan 20 ans un jour
ce hacker autodidacte a eu une idée
redoutable gt1 soir installé ici dans
mon canapé juste là et puis je regardais
un film sur l'écran de droite là bas et
j'ai eu l'idée comme ça vous pouvez me
montrez nous faire une petite démo de
comment ça comment ça se fait moi je
peux à chaud vous montrer comment ce
fait une dimension c'est la
démonstration sera plutôt technique
ça doit être un gosse que je vais
commencer ce que nous retiendrons c'est
que dylan a inventé un moyen de vous
faire envoyer des sms surtaxés sans que
vous ne puissiez les détecter
tout cela parce que vous vous êtes
procuré sur un site de téléchargement
illégal
une application qui l'a lui même infecté
donc il me l'a pour l'instant il reste
juste a ajouté le numéro de téléphone
sur lequel on va renvoyer les sms qui
seront arrivés d'accord pour la
démonstration
le virus est programmée voilà en théorie
les sms payant qu'il génère ne sont pas
visibles mais pour l'expérience
nous avons demandé à dylan de les rendre
apparent sur notre téléphone
il envoie ce que dylan réalise
aujourd'hui pour nous sous forme
d'expérience il l'a fait dans la vraie
vie pendant presque toute l'année 2012
il empochait une partie de l'argent des
sms à savoir 4000 euros quant aux
particuliers ils n'avaient pas
connaissance de ces sms avant d'avoir
épluché leur facture téléphonique
et encore on pourrait si on l'a ce
téléphone allumé pendant chez pendant 10
minutes admettons ça va
donc ça s'était caché l'utilisateur ne
le voyez pas ça c'est cash utilisateurs
ne le voyez pas au total plus de 20000
utilisateurs ont envoyé à cause de dylan
ces sms payants les escroqueries de ce
genre aurait été multiplié par cent en
d'après les professionnels de la
sécurité pour dylan en tout cas cela ne
s'est pas très bien terminé de formation
en fête et de formation donc j'arrive
devant la porte d'entrée
là où j'habite il y avait deux personnes
qui m'attendais donc et me disent
bonjour monsieur police de nanterre donc
je veux bonjour vous êtes bien vous êtes
bien jeune bah oui c'est moi et là ils
le disent
bon ben voilà on vient vous voir parce
que vous êtes accusé de deux intrusions
dans les systèmes de traitement
automatisé de données
dylan sera arrêté jugé puis condamné à
un an de prison dont 6 mois qu'il purge
à domicile avec un bracelet électronique
pour la suite
comme beaucoup d'anciens hackers ils
souhaitent se reconvertir dans la
sécurité des smartphones et nous allons
voir que le secteur est en plein
développement
[Musique]
à laval nous avons rendez vous dans une
école d'ingénieur d'un genre nouveau
une dizaine d'élèves travaille
exclusivement sur la sécurité des
smartphones dans un laboratoire aux noms
évocateurs cryptologie et virologie
voici leurs professeurs c'est l'expert
en piratage qui avait réalisé pour nous
la reconstitution dans le restaurant
aujourd'hui les étudiants vont mener une
autre expérience sous nos yeux est allé
encore plus loin
ils vont se connecter un smartphone et
déjouer une à une toutes les barrières
de sécurité
objectif récupérer un maximum
d'informations cacher derrière chaque
application donc des sms base de données
des comptes gmail des comptes de
messagerie le compte facebook
la totale tout ce qui est relié à une
application sur le téléphone là encore
il suffit de subtiliser pendant quelques
instants le mobile de votre cible et
maintenant ils en attendent du téléphone
que je proches qui les a trouvés en
général c'est fini ça prend entre une
minute une minute trente selon la
quantité de données les données vont
être analysés par les étudiants merci
ils ont mis au point un logiciel très
simple qui permet de les lire un
particulier peut facilement faire de
même donc ici on voit la liste de tous
les sms
donc on peut voir ici les adresses donc
le numéro de téléphone que la date
d'envoi et la date de réception
on peut voir ici tout le corps du
message
donc on peut voir ici un hoquet j'aurais
vise à ôter coucou ici c'est la chose la
plus intéressante
tous les comptes que vous avez
enregistré sur votre téléphone les mails
le compte facebook le compte twitter
vous mail personnelle et professionnelle
etc sont enregistrées dans un fichier et
on peut voir ici à l'écran que le mot de
passe et afficher tout de suite en clair
pour les pirates
il est beaucoup plus facile de récupérer
nos mots de passe sur nos smartphones
que sur nos ordinateurs
tout à fait on a eu ça on a eu ces
informations en à peine une minute
en branchant votre petit don au
téléphone est sous nos yeux
les étudiants vont découvrir une faille
majeure qu'il n'aurait jamais soupçonnée
elle expose le propriétaire du
smartphone mais aussi son entourage
je viens de trouver que les informations
de tous vos amis facebook font en clair
sur le téléphone donc je viens de voir
le nom et le prénom de tous mes amis
facebook leur email
leur numéro de téléphone leur date
d'anniversaire et leurs statuts sur
facebook et tout ceci est en clair sur
le téléphone si tu trouve des trucs
comme ça c'est une pub ou quoi c'est pas
beaucoup si c'est fou nous soyons clairs
fin c'est pas une petite icône vous avez
bien de nos étudiants quand il trouve
des choses comme ça ah ben oui parce que
vous savez partie de la pédagogie c'est
de les mettre face à des vrais problèmes
et de leur laisser la bride moi g
j'ai une seule règle c'est jordan
d'objectifs et je laisse me surprendre
avec les résultats en forme sont tout
d'abord des ingénieurs avec une bonne
formation mathématique informatique
en revanche le point de vue du hacker et
notamment son attachement à la chose
opérationnel et aux résultats oui c'est
une qualité qu'on cherchait d'évoluer
dans leurs travaux pratiques les
étudiants pour mission de corriger ces
failles de sécurité et de mettre au
point un antivirus à la sortie de
l'école ils travailleront dans la
cybersécurité leur labo est d'ailleurs
rattaché au ministère de la défense car
l'état est directement concernée
on pourrait par exemple si si le
président un téléphone samsung par
exemple ici on pourrait le hacker il
suffirait de subtiliser le téléphone
d'une façon ou d'une autre que ce soit
dans son entourage
c'est peut provenir de l'intérieur de
l'elysée ça peut être n'importe qui
pourrait voilà avoir accès physique à ce
téléphone est ensuite injecté un
programme qui permettrait de contrôler
téléphone en fait le président de la
république pour les communications
officielles est équipé d'un téléphone
ultra sécurisé construit par une marque
française du genre de ceux que l'on
trouve dans ce salon à lille celui ci
par exemple est accessible aux
particuliers moyennant 2000 euros
car les deux premiers
moment
nous sommes dans le plus grand salon
français consacré à la cybersécurité il
est organisé par la gendarmerie
nationale dans une ambiance anxiogène la
démonstration s'enchaînent devant des
professionnels du renseignement des
hackers quelques ministres et des
représentants de sociétés de
cybersécurité
certaines d'entre elles réalisent un
milliard et demi d'euros de chiffres
d'affaires et leurs noms restent
totalement inconnues du grand public
ici ce ne sont pas seulement les secrets
d'état que l'on cherche à protéger mais
aussi et surtout les secrets industriels
c'est ce que nous explique cet ingénieur
on a des exemples concrets de sociétés
qui vont se travailler sur un appel
d'offres à l'étranger et qui bizarrement
père cet appel d'offres et qui se rend
compte que société qu'à gagner était sur
une proposition techniquement
comparables à des prix comparables et
qui ont le doute de savoir si quelqu'un
pendant qu'ils étaient au resto pendant
qu'ils étaient 1 chambre d'hôtel ou
ailleurs n'a pas dupliquer les
informations et accéder à leurs données
pour essaie des choses qui se passent
tous les jours car nous allons voir
qu'avec l'arrivée des smartphones
les entreprises sont devenues beaucoup
plus vulnérable au coeur du problème
cette nouvelle pratique qui consiste
pour les salariés a apporté au travail
leur propre appareil il connecte par
exemple leurs tablettes ou leur
smartphone aux serveurs de la société
celle-ci ne s'y oppose pas toujours car
elles réalisent des économies en anglais
le phénomène a été baptisé bring your
own device le biode patrick est
responsable de la sécurité informatique
d'une grande société française qui
compte 130 mille employés
pour lui le bio fait courir un risque
aux entreprises avec le phénomène du
viol les données l'entreprise se
retrouve effectivement stockés à
différents endroits un petit peu partout
chaque collaborateur peut mettre en
péril toute l'entreprise
s'il perd son téléphone si il se fait
voler sa tablette effectivement puisque
depuis ces périphériques on peut se
reconnecter au réseau de l'entreprise et
de la accéder à tout un tas
d'informations sensibles confidentiel
potentiellement des brevets des choses
comme ça donc ce qui fragilise
effectivement réellement l'entreprise
c'est parce qu'il est possible de se
connecter de son smartphone au réseau de
l'entreprise que de nouveaux scénarios
de piratage voit le jour
exemple avec cette expérience
le spécialiste en sécurité va téléphoner
en numéro masqué à une de ses collègues
et se faire passer pour un technicien
cette fois c'est la faille humaine qui
va ouvrir les portes du réseau
informatique
oui bonjour laetitia oui bonjour c'est
fred du support informatique de la boîte
et j'ai un petit problème avec ton
compte j'arrive pas à le configurer
comme j'aimerais pour le temps qui
fonctionne bien et j'aurais besoin
éventuellement que tu changes ton autres
parce que tu sais comment faire ben
écoute pour tout simplifier un peu la
vie je te propose de de changer son mot
de passe et puis de mettre un truc
simple genre password tu vois toi comme
ça ça va tu sais faire
d'accord impeccable merci salut
et voilà grâce au manque de vigilance de
l'employé l'usurpateur en possession du
nouveau mot de passe pourra se connecter
à distance aux serveurs de la société et
pillé des données le smartphone permet
donc d'entrer par effraction dans la vie
secrète des entreprises et dans
l'intimité des abonnés et cette clé
permettra aussi demain de forcer les
coffres-forts
si les ingénieurs ne l'a sécurise pas
davantage car il est déjà possible de
payer avec son téléphone portable
c'est ce qu'on appelle le paiement sans
contact direction nice où un test à
grande échelle est menée en ce moment
par la ville et par les opérateurs
téléphoniques démonstration dès
l'arrivée au moment de prendre le tram
avec laurent l'un des concepteurs du
projet qu il passe le téléphone sur un
autocollant pour acheter un billet
alors j'achète un titre de transport et
j'achète de n'importe quel ticket
transports selon les usages que je veux
en faire on sur le téléphone qui seront
sur le téléphone est hébergé sur le
téléphone votre smartphone se substitue
effectivement à la carte de transport
et lorsque nous montons dans le tram
l'appareil permettent également de
valider même quand il est éteint alors
le geste de validation et le même
strictement le même l'avantagé c'est que
même si mon téléphone n'a plus de
batterie ça fonctionne aussi patriote
ça ça c'est intéressant puisqu'on peut
quand même tombé en peu quand même
tombés en panne de batterie pour payer
sans contact il suffit de s'être procuré
une carte sim particulière qui contient
les informations bancaires
par la suite nous avons pu tester
l'achat d'une douceur dans une
boulangerie
[Musique]
puis nous avons commandé un espresso
dans un bar
chez un marchand de souvenirs qui
participent à l'expérience
nous avons emporté un bibelot tout
fonctionne parfaitement mais un détail
attire notre attention
pas besoin d'entrer de code confidentiel
pour les montants inférieurs à 20 euros
ce système est il réellement fiable nous
retournons voir patrick chan bay
l'expert en sécurité
son service est en train de tester une
application de paiement sans contact
celle ci présente des failles de
sécurité des brèches dans lesquelles des
pirates peuvent s'introduire pour voler
vos données
donc on va faire une synthèse de
vulnérabilité qu'on a trouvée puisque on
a trouvé quand même pas mal et puis on
va lister les recommandations pour
corriger ces vulnérabilités et permettre
à notre client de mettre en place un
plan d'action de sécurisation de son
infrastructure en simulant un piratage
l'équipe a pu récupérer beaucoup
d'informations leur verdict est sans
appel
l'application doit être sécurisé avant
d'être mise sur le marché
mais cette nouvelle technologie a
peut-être déjà dans votre portefeuille
sans que vous ne le sachiez
car les nouvelles cartes bancaires sont
équipés d'une de ces puces de paiement
sans contact
et là encore la sécurité n'est pas au
rendez vous nous allons le démontrer
avec un smartphone et une application
téléchargée sur internet en quelques
secondes
nom prénom numéro de carte date
d'expiration et historique des derniers
achats apparaît sous nos yeux
un pirate va pouvoir lire votre carte
bleue même si vous l'avez rangé dans
votre portefeuille
bien à l'abri sous vos vêtements pour
patrick la technologie du sans contact
elle même n'est pas en cause ce sont les
concepteurs qui négligent la sécurité
des utilisateurs
ceux qui développent des applications
n'ont pas encore intégré des mesures de
sécurisation de leurs applications dont
qu'ils développent de manière non
sécurisés et cette dernière de l'été qui
permettent depuis l'internet de prendre
le contrôle complet des applications qui
sont ouvertes sur internet d'accéder à
la base de données cas derrière de la
lyre d'éventuellement de la modifier des
choses comme ça si les industriels
innove en permanence ils le font parfois
un peu trop vite sans penser à la
protection des consommateurs
ces derniers peuvent compter sur des
experts comme patrick pour renforcer la
sécurité des smartphones en attendant
comment se prémunir des pirates dès
aujourd'hui pour cela il faut faire un
petit voyage dans le temps ou plutôt
dans les hangars de france télécom qui
conserve tous les téléphones depuis les
origines jusqu'aux derniers modèles de
smartphones
patrice battiston et le gardien de cette
collection est très bientôt notre
smartphone arrivera sur ses étagères
[Musique]
je pense qu'avec l'évolution des des
équipements des services dans un an un
an et demi sera il intégrera la
collection historique de la maison il y
a 20 ans l'ancêtre du téléphone portable
était loin de ressembler à un ordinateur
il avait plutôt une tête de boîte à
outils et dix ans plus tard
ses mobiles étaient encore loin de vous
dire le temps qu'il fait loin de
recevoir des emails tout juste les
premiers sms et quelques jeux et ce sont
finalement ces portables très basique
qui résistent le mieux aux pirates car
ils sont déconnectés de la toile
contiennent peu d'informations et pas
d'application
[Musique]
il offre à ce reportage une conclusion
étonnante contre les téléphones
préhistorique qui dorment dans nos
tiroirs les espions ne peuvent rien ou
presque
je